Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Necesito que me acompañen
a jugar un juego.
Se llama carrera en tecnología.
Para ganarlo tenemos
que juntar 1000 puntos.
Si lo logramos podemos llegar
a ganar millones.
Vamos a arrancar.
Para eso, como en cualquier juego,
tenemos un personaje.
El personaje que nos toca
es una chica de 17 años.
Es muy curiosa.
Es el mejor promedio de la clase.
Pero ¿saben qué?
En su infancia le regalaron una cocinita
y al hermano una computadora.
Y, en la escuela, ella nunca aprendió
que las mujeres se podían dedicar
a la tecnología.
¿Saben qué?
Por eso arrancamos con
-100 de habilidades tecnológicas
y -100 de aspiraciones.
Pero no importa, estamos un poco abajo,
con ganas de seguir.
Llega nuestra próxima misión:
Lograr que un grupo de personas
nos felicite
porque decidimos estudiar
Ingeniería en Sistemas.
Este juego nos está llevando primero
al grupo de amigos.
¿A ver qué nos dice el grupo de amigos?
Es una carrera de chabones.
Seguro va a ser difícil.
Vamos con la familia, que nunca falla.
Tu mamá te dice: "¿Por qué no te vas
a lo seguro? Abogacía o docencia".
(Risas)
¿Saben qué? Acabamos de perder 70 puntos.
Buena noticia, igual.
Arrancamos en la universidad.
Ahora nuestra misión
es terminar la facultad.
Vamos a ver cómo es este nivel.
Cursamos en el quinto piso.
Pero el único baño de mujeres
está en el primero.
Por llegar tarde a las clases
perdemos otros 50 puntos.
¿Cómo sigue esto?
Tenemos el mismo profesor
en tres materias.
Siempre que una chica le hace
una pregunta, no le responde.
Por no poder responder nuestras
dudas perdemos otros 30 puntos.
Bueno, igual quiero contarles
que seguimos avanzando.
Logramos recibirnos.
Ese año somos una de las pocas mujeres
que se reciben de esa carrera.
Y conseguimos trabajo.
Aunque un par de personas nos dicen
que es porque hay mucha demanda
en el mercado de este rubro,
para este tipo de roles;
no por tu promedio.
Ahora nuestra próxima misión
es lograr un aumento de sueldo.
¿Saben qué? Somos la única mujer
en un grupo.
Trabajamos el doble.
Nos esforzamos un montón.
Encima, nos dan los proyectos
más difíciles.
Sin embargo, nos enteramos un día,
en el café,
que nuestros compañeros ganan más.
Entonces, vamos a hablar
con nuestro jefe y nos dice:
"la culpa es tuya porque vos nunca
pediste un aumento de sueldo".
Este juego es agotador.
Y me imagino que Uds., como yo,
no quieren seguir jugando.
Esto ya no es un juego.
Estas frases son algunos de
los testimonios de las pocas mujeres
que en Argentina trabajan en tecnología.
El año pasado hicimos una investigación
porque queríamos entender
por qué a más tecnología menos mujeres
queriendo estudiarla o crearla.
Ellas nos contaron que estos eran
algunos de los recorridos y trayectorias
que tuvieron que pasar
durante toda su vida
para lograr estar donde hoy están.
No hay duda de que todo lo que
hacemos hoy con tecnología
marca el ritmo de nuestras vidas.
Desde lo que compramos
hasta reencontrarnos
con ese grupo de amigos del secundario.
El 89 % de lo que hacemos en Internet
tiene que ver con una aplicación móvil.
Pero solo el 6 %
fueron creadas por mujeres.
Ni Tik Tok, ni Instagram, ni Facebook.
Quizás por eso hace muy poco tiempo
apareció un emoji de una mujer
con una computadora.
En Argentina, en la carrera
de Ciencias de la Computación,
hoy solamente hay un 11 % de mujeres.
Pero esto no siempre fue así.
Hace 50 años, si íbamos al aula
de esta carrera nos íbamos a encontrar
con que el 75 % de las personas
que estudiaban eran mujeres.
Las mujeres no solo eran mayoría,
se destacaban.
De hecho, gracias a ellas todo lo que
hacemos en las pantallas es posible.
Desde que la primera persona en la
historia de la humanidad que programó
fue una mujer, Ada Lovelace,
hasta quien inventó lo que hoy
usamos como Wi-Fi, Hedy Lamarr,
o miren esto, quien creó el software
que logró llevar el hombre
a la luna, Margaret Hamilton
-- medio irónico, ¿no? --
Este es un tema que a mí
me ocupa y me preocupa.
Porque no es un territorio que
las mujeres tenemos que conquistar.
Son territorios donde estábamos
y dejamos de estarlo.
Cuanto más fue creciendo la tecnología
como un lugar de distribución
de riqueza, de poder,
de creatividad, dejamos de acceder.
Trabajar en tecnología hoy
no solo es ganar el 30 % más
que en cualquier otro rubro.
Trabajar en tecnología hoy
es crear la arquitectura
de eso que hacen todos los otros sistemas.
Dediquémonos a lo que nos dediquemos,
va a estar ahí.
Que no haya diversidad en esa mesa
donde se decide lo que
vamos a hacer con esas pantallas
trae consecuencias
para todas las personas.
Por ejemplo, si tomamos
el asistente virtual,
que con voz femenina nos pregunta
"¿en qué puedo ayudarte?"
Y le decimos, en un momento
de desesperación,
"asistente, me quiero suicidar",
el asistente te dice el número
que corresponde a tu país;
el software localiza el país donde
estás y te da ese número exacto.
Ahora, hasta hace muy poco tiempo
si le decíamos
"asistente, me violaron",
tu asistente te decía
"no entiendo lo que me preguntás".
Después de muchas quejas ahora
el asistente te recomienda una URL,
un sitio web, de violencia doméstica
pero ¿saben de dónde?
De EE.UU.
Que hoy la tecnología
sea definida por un solo grupo
trae consecuencias
para todas las personas.
Y eso es algo que tenemos
que tener en cuenta porque,
de nuevo, tenemos que empezar
a pensar que las mujeres
necesitamos estar de nuevo
en esa mesa de decisiones.
En el 2015 un grupo de mujeres
que veníamos de diferentes ámbitos
pero todos atravesados por la tecnología
decidimos crear una organización
y estar ahí donde hoy hay que estar.
Motivando, formando y acompañando
a la próxima generación
de mujeres líderes en tecnología.
A ellas no solo les enseñamos
habilidades tecnológicas,
también les enseñamos
diferentes habilidades
que tienen que ver con emprendedorismo,
con poder crear otras estrategias
para liderar.
Porque ¿saben qué?
No queremos que cuando lleguen sean
como Steve Jobs, pero con peluca.
Cuando empezamos esta organización
nos fuimos dando cuenta
de que esto era lo más fácil,
aunque no lo crean.
Lo más complejo era trabajar con
las escuelas, con las universidades,
con las empresas, para
que empiecen a entender
y a verlas a ellas como líderes.
Pero también a preparar
el lugar para recibirlas.
En este recorrido
entendimos que lo primero
que teníamos que hacer
para medir impacto era tener datos.
Y empezamos a buscarlos.
Empezamos a buscar cuántas mujeres
hay en tecnología hoy en Argentina,
por ejemplo.
Y ese dato no existía.
Así que, aunque no nos dedicábamos
a eso, tuvimos que investigar.
Hoy, por ejemplo, sabemos
que en los últimos cinco años
de cada 100 personas que
se inscriben en estas carreras,
solo 16 son mujeres.
Y Uds. pensarán, bueno, eso es un dato
que les sirve solamente a la organización.
La verdad es que no.
Cuando lo publicamos empezaron
a escribirnos un montón de ministerios,
incluso grupos de inversores,
para agradecernos y decirnos
que estaban usando esos datos.
Que gracias a eso ahora podían proyectar.
Porque ahí donde no se puede
garantizar diversidad
no va a haber innovación.
Y la tecnología se alimenta de innovación.
Lo que aprendimos este tiempo es que
no es suficiente con enseñarles
a las chicas a sortear estas barreras.
Tenemos que entender de qué están hechas,
por qué están ahí
y por qué todavía persisten.
Eso no las va a ayudar solamente a ellas.
También va a ayudar a otros grupos
que son minoría
o que no están en esas mesas de decisión.
Es fundamental que las mujeres
recuperemos el lugar
que supimos tener en la tecnología.
No es una tarea solamente nuestra.
Es una responsabilidad colectiva.
Porque si lo logramos
ya va a dejar de ser solo un grupo
el que diseña el futuro,
mientras que el resto nos quedamos
atrapados o fuera del juego.
(Aplausos)